c'est
ah sonnerie des années 90 il y a déjà
une surprise pour qui est cette surprise
je vais répondre alors là vous allez
voir là c'est l'acteur que vous allez
voir je vais répondre faire genre il y a
quelqu'un au bout du fil ça Roch allô
j'écoute écoutez-moi bien c'est qui à
l'pparis tu m'entends oui c'est qui
comment tu vas ça va et toi bon écoute
bien alors apparemment c'est une
surprise pour quelqu'un autour de ce
plateau quelqu'un qui a une première
surprise quelqu'un qui est qui est venu
lu rendre visite quelqu'un qui a compté
pour lui dans les années 90 est-ce qu'on
peut avoir est-ce qu'on peut avoir un
premier indice allez prier indice
premier indice je faisais l'école
buissonnièire avec une personne présente
sur le plateau c'est bon c'est pour
[Rires]
vous alors apparemment les chroniqueurs
pens à moi estceon un deuxième indice
euh AZ B deième indice grâce à cette
personne j'ai échappé un raquette ah
ouais fort ah ouais alors à qui vous
pensez c'est clair ça peut être vous ou
Raymon je dirais Mo moi ou Raymon est-ce
qu'on a un troisème
indice la personne en question adore les
bateaux c'est pas moi je
raccroche
alors je pense que c'est pour
moi est-ce qu'on peut faire venir à la
première surprise la soire et et voir de
qui il s'agit c'est parti est-ce qu'on
peut me dire même dans l'oreillette les
chér oh là oh
[Applaudissements]
non
dans tu toujours au FO ou pas c'est lui
avec mon fils tu jouis tu jouais très
bien je me débrou ah si c'était très
beauontoitoii on dirait g en plus jeune
ouis c'est vrai il est plus beau
là je suis trop content de te voir vous
CZ souvent je l'adore c'est un gars qui
était dans ma classe on é on a fait
plein de class ensemble on a pas que
cellel on a fait plein de classes
ensemble regardez alors tu étais là tu
étais avec moi là on a pas une autre
classe ah ouais ah ouais ah ouais tu
étais là ah ouais beau pull frère de
pull de
pull moi j'ai l'impression que je me l'
raconé déjà non mais sans déconner c'est
insupportable insupportable Flor
tellement cont de voir tu sais que je te
kiffais mais je te
jure me cont mais moi aussi tu sais un
des mecs je plus on s pas vu depuis je
sais
pas c'est un des mecs que je préférais à
l'école on se kiffé de ouf c'est vrai
app ou pas Monf ouais je me souvensoi
cette
histoire il a échappé un raquette
apparemment ou quoiandandant du en
sortant du gymnase on était au collège à
mariecury au Lila et on s'est fait
agress par des mecs donc en sortant du
du gymnas de marieury voulait ma dououne
en plus il voulait sa dououne et tu
avais une sorte de sacoche ouais et tu
leur filais des coups de
sacoche et tu as réussi à
dégager la doudoune elle part pas la
dououn f quoi la dououn tu pouvais
mourir pour la doudoun frre tu es fou
quoi la doudoune elle ne part pas c
incroyable ça comment ça s terminé alors
après oh il est partti en courant moi
aussi et il a réussi à se dégager ils
lui ont pas pris sa doudoune jamais la
doudoune elle parle pas
frère il se laissait pas faire c non
franchement on a rigolé ouais
franchement c'était incroyable tu
travaillais bien toi d'ailleurs ouais ça
va si pas mal toi tu étais toujours dans
le bon to ouais
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai tu compopiais
pas un peu sur toi un moment ouais c'est
possible c'est possible tu faisais déjà
beau courir la classe à l'époque ouais
c'est vra cétait déjà on rigolait ouiou
on s'est bien Maré tu avais une meuf ou
pas toi à l'époque je me rappelle plus
non pas de meuf mais toi oui c'est
vrai c'est qui la meu toi tu tu kiffais
bien Mélanie Mélanie Godin c'est vrai
raison c'est vrai c'est vrai tu te
souviens des nom de famille ah oui mais
c'est des trucs que tu oublies
pas non non c'est vrai ou et tu es sorti
avec Lise exa c'est vrai tuê
mais il
est monstre monstre je me rappelle une
blonde avec les cheveux elice ln il se
rappelle du Rapp pas c'est vrai c'est
ouf oui ou ah ouais elice ln elle
travaillit très bienou gen prè c'est la
première de la classe genre je suis pas
première maisou ouais ouais je sais
ouais elle avait des cheveux très très
longs c'est ça blonds ouais c'est ça
exactement je m'en rappelles c'est vrai
c'est vrai elle venait d'un autre lycée
elle est arrivé en cours d'année en 3e
c'est vrai et tu l'as chopé
direct dans les par de la voiture dans
les feux de la voiture elle est passé
dans les feux de la voiture trè en 3èè
il y en a pas une dernière non mais
c'est mon ouais attend a plein d'anecdot
ou je sais pas moi je sais qu'on
rigolait beaucoup en musique quand on
apprenait euhou je sais pas si tu te
souviens les deux chansons qu'on avait
appris la Ziza et
ouais parce que changis les paroles des
chansons ouais je sais pas tu faisais
des
conneries Laziza et je marche au seul
ouais exactement te rappelles quand j'ai
chantais je marche seul au tu t'en
rappelle oui je m'en souviens c'était
quoi c'était quoi c'était ouf parce que
nous on on était une classe on avait une
prof de musique madame kerems c'est ça
pas une blonde commass ouais un avion de
chasse et donc elle est arrivé et donc
céit un truc de ouf parce que il y avait
une estrade rappelles ou pas et genre
elle appelait genre les gens qui
allaient chanter elle faisait comme ça
allez Anouna va nous chanter je marche
au SE et là la guerre j'ai arrivé frère
te rappelles comment j'avais chanté de
ouf le feu dans la classe le feu le feu
mais toi je me rappelle tu étais très
bon foot avec wilfriedère qui jou bien
aussi ouais jeis que ça me fait
plaisir de te voir est-ce que tu aurais
imaginé que C deviendrait la personne
qu' est aujourd'hui une grosse Moula
c'est un truc non une grosse Moula ouais
c'est une grosse Moula c'est une star
quoi c'est c'est un un businessman ah
oui par rapport à ça non mais c'est des
trucs tu peux pas tu peux pas prévoir
mais il était déjà il éit déjà Maré tout
le monde il avait déjà beaucoup
d'assurance et tu étais délégué aussi je
crois
ouais Capello donc après c'est des trucs
tu peux pas t'y attendre à ce point-là
non franchement
les trajires tu pe déjà agité je t déjà
agité et et Florent tu fais quoi toi
maintenant moi je je suis développeur je
su un truc beaucoup plus tu as l'air
bien tu es bien dans ta vie oui ça va ou
tu es marié ouais je suis marié j'ai
avec une femme formidable je l'embrasse
ah moi aussi et j'ai deux gosses super
ça va tout se passe
bien j'adore cette ville ah ouais tu
connais
montpellieréta oui je
connais bien Montpellier pas changé
franchement je connais comment fait
comment fait que tu es parti sur
Montpellier toi j'ai suivi ma femme elle
est médecin ah ouais elle a fait ses
études de médecine à montpier je
rejoppappelle de mon père il nous
regarde oui il était ouf un peu aussi te
rappelle je me souviens plus des gâteaux
de ta mère ah
ouais parce que j'enis des gâteaux au
prof pour les AM
c'est vrai mais Flo tu à la maison ou
pas bah pour manger les gâteaux de ta
mère quand tu étais pas là vous l'z
reconnu vous l'EZ reconnu changé il a
pas changé c'est un truc Flo il a pas
changé la même t tu veux que je te dis
je préfère tap coup
maintenant non mais c'est vrai c'est
incroyable que je suis comme un fou
parce Flo bravoip parce que tu sais
vraiment je te jure que tu es un des
mecs que je kiffais le plus que floent
c'était un mec il était toujours dans la
rigolade tu sais le bon camarade tu vois
il y avait une Dara il il voulait en
être c'est vrai tu étais toujours là
pour une rigolade un truc ouais on se
marit bien c'é franement je suis très
heureux de te voir et si a besoin de
quelque chose à part de
l'oseille vraiment t'hésites pas mon
vraiment ça me ferait hyper plaisir sa
que si je viis à Montpelier je vais
t'appeler ou je vais à can souvent ah
ouais comment parfis pourqui j'ai
regardé le complément d'enquête j'ai vu
que
tu
incroyable franchement
je vous avez vu il est il a il est d' il
a rien à dire il est d' éta es venu de
Montpellier que pour moi ouais ouais
ouais ah mais ils m'ont appelé j'ai pas
hésité je suis venu direct ça me fait
hyper plaisir de te voir pareil ouis et
te Rapp je me rappelle il y av il y
avait Cyril chauaille aussi avec moi
chauille à droite je me souviens pas de
tous les noms mais M Arbaoui la photo
qu'on a vu en haut c'est Cyr Gouo
audessus de moi et Serge Bario vous vous
souvenez
mêmeom fois non mais en tout cas restes
un peu avec nous ça me fait plaisir he
et si vous avez des questions à poser à
Flo n'hésitez pas Florent Molf en tout
cas et si tu veux qu'on fasse un foot je
suis là mais sûr tu étais moi je me
rappelle de toi tu étais hyper bon au
foot oua ou je ouais on jouit toujours
dans la cour avec Stéphane Dubord ou un
truc ouais Stéphane Galati aussi
Stéphane Galati mais il jouit pas foot
tu sais que Stéphan Galati a péchau
Mélanie Godin non je te le jure que
c'est vrai j'étais étonné frère c'était
votre meuf de l'époque non mais non
c'était son crush C CR son crush oua je
app ch Stéphane Galati ouais
mauvaisû était bien je l'adore mais
c'était pas quand même il était moins
bien c'était pas ouf il avait une pe cou
comass frère et toi non
ouais mais non c'est fan Galati je me
rappelle j'allais jouer chez lui frère
ouais on joue au foot avec des chaises
non mais mais du coup cine il avait
beaucoup de succès parce qu'il était
beau gosse ou parce qu'il avait beaucoup
de
chatch les deux je pense une voiture non
il chatchit beaucoup ouais et puis il
était il était beau
aussi toi fl tu vas me gêner tu vas me
gêner FL non mais je vous jure que c'est
un mec incroyable c'est des mecs voilà
comme comme on kiffe et franchement tu
as connu ta femme toi ouais euh au lycée
c'était une des meilleures amies de
Mélanie au lycée gnial comment s'appelle
Johanna Johan comment Johan Bismut c'est
la la cousine de Charlie Charlie Bismut
Charlie tayb ouais je sais pas tuas
échangé par texto avec lui il y a pas
très longtemps il me semble ça te dit
quelque chose non ouais ça te dit rien
non c'est vrai je c'est un Tommy hein
fais attention à
luire en tout cas je suis très content
que tu sois là Florent mondolpo qui
était dans la classe c'est une belle
surprise c'est une belle surprise